what up y'all
so many technical difficulties because
i'm doing this by myself and i'm
learning as we go but here we go y'all
ladies and gentlemen welcome to
another live episode of your favorite
podcast
[Music]
all right ladies and gentlemen we are
here it was championship weekend
got to talk about that i went to the
game i was at sofi
most exciting game i've ever been to
the sporting event i've ever been to in
my life
uh make sure you guys subscribe share
and all that kind of stuff we're going
to talk about that we're going to talk
about both teams all the games we're
going to talk about tom brady retiring
[Music]
also i'm going to get into boba fett
and archive 81 on netflix but ladies and
gentlemen thanks for being here
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
man
so many technical difficulties but
anyways make sure you like subscribe
share and do all that great stuff but uh
first i just want to say a little bit
about one of our sponsors and that is a
doordash everybody doordash
um
wait
here we go doordash uh doordash connects
you with everything you want whenever
and however you want it get 25 off and
zero delivery fees on your first order
of 15 or more when you download the door
dash app and enter code griffin enter
code griffin on the door dash app
okay i'm starting off today um with
this uh the
i hate my boyfriend's couch picture
because there is news
we are getting a new couch
new couch on the way so i just wanted to
put that up there right now just to say
i find finally getting a new couch and
i'm actually on board with it i i wanted
a new couch because i i just discount
this leather it's old but it's you know
it's not that's necessarily comfortable
to like lay on and watch tv or just sit
and cuddle with rachel so we're getting
a new couch uh so shout out to hd
buttercup that's the company that we're
getting the couch from got me good got a
good deal so it is what it is and um you
know
it is what it is so like i say
make sure you guys make sure to
subscribe share hit the notifications
because i am going to be doing a lot
more live episodes but i'm also
i did my first patreon only youtube
members only video because i'm doing
that now once a week too and maybe even
more and that what i'll do there for the
first couple of months i'm gonna go live
on youtube so anybody can see it but
then if you want to re-watch it you got
to be a youtube member or if you didn't
catch it you got to be a patreon member
or youtube member so i do have last
week's video up on patreon right now so
shout out to all the patreon members who
are a part of that and so i'm going to
you know be doing more content there you
know i'd really love to just move
rifleman griffin directly to patreon
actually but you know i'm not going to
do that yet i like giving you free
content it is what it is uh and by the
way i'm also on twitch uh daily eric
griffin gaming so look out for that
please subscribe to that channel too uh
subscribe share make sure you follow and
subscribe
follow mostly uh subscribe if you want
to because you know what that that's
about
so
yeah man
all right
let us get into
it
let's get into it okay so i went to
the
um
i went to sofi
and
i went and saw
the championship game y'all
went and saw the game and it was
it really was exciting i mean i think
that this is the most
exciting
football playoffs that i've seen
probably i don't know maybe ever
i don't know if there's ever been a more
exciting playoffs
with any team has a chance to win
with like so many great performances so
many like there's disappointments and
then there's like you know people
living up to expectations exceeding
expectations not living you know what i
mean all that it was great
all right so first let me tell you about
excuse me my experience going to the
game all right so
so far stadium nightmare
let me just open with that so far
stadium is a nightmare the stadium looks
beautiful it is state of the art i mean
i've never it was so
spectacular the field and just the
stands and everything that was involved
with that
getting to the stadium ridiculous okay
parking
ridiculous
to get in and out of that parking lot
was a nightmare man
okay so you get you know so you get um
well okay first let me just say this
shout out to my buddy chris
um they they own restaurants and and
comedy club and and him and his buddies
you know they invite me to these kind of
things all the time and i'm always out
of town or something but this time i was
available but i didn't know they had it
like this okay so they sent me the
ticket
we're in this on-field bungalow all
right so they sent me a ticket to send
me a parking ticket and all that stuff
right so shout out to them they invite
me to clippers games all the time they
invite me to stuff all the time i
finally went okay and he's like it's
gonna be a good group of people and i'm
like all right and this it really is a
bunch of cool ass rich white guys you
know and they real cool dudes you know
they down to earth cool dudes you know
what i mean but it is what it is you
know so anyways
pull up to the stadium it's a nightmare
to get to the parking lot the way they
got it set up is just they need to fix
that so far
fix your parking situation because you
can't even get there all right it's
crazy so you finally i finally get to
like and then it's like or it says like
orange like
it says championship parking so they
hyping it up like you think you you know
you think you right there you not you
gotta go everybody's right there
so then i gotta walk a country mile to
go to uh to get to like where i'm in so
on the ticket it says vip
so it goes you you know vip entrance 12.
so you know anytime you see the words
vip you like okay
i'm vip finally getting treated where i
feel like i should be treated you know
all that nonsense right so then
i um
you know you get there and it's a mad
house y'all and by the way i was two
hours early everybody was two hours
early all right so the vip area this
entrance
it is just swamped with people there's
like seven different lines that aren't
really lines so it's like we're curving
around and then another line is like
wave going way back that way so i just
kind of get in line with other people
and then one of the guys comes over one
of the rams uh
so five people come over like this isn't
a line the line starts back there so
then we all move and then another line
where we were still forms and it's just
a mad house so i text a guy and i go yo
man i'm here but
this vip ain't vip
and he goes
all right
he says you know what i'm gonna come
down and get you ask i hate when people
do this like you know they think they
special they think they're making you
feel special and they go just go to the
front and ask for so and so
excuse me i'm like i hate doing that
because i don't want to get up there and
be like hey is so-and-so here and then
all of a sudden they like
no who are you like what's going on and
you like damn but my homeboy said you
know what i mean so i said are you sure
because i this is a mad house and i
ain't walking up here making a fool of
myself because now people are starting
to recognize me too and it's like yo man
you really funny all this kind of stuff
and it's like you know i'm with y'all
like i ain't special
you know what i mean
so then he goes because jeremy renner
was there okay he was in our group
right hawkeye
cool dude i'm gonna get to that
he goes he's up in the front already uh
they're getting him in on some side side
stuff you know on some like i'm an
avengers type vibe so i was like all
right so i finally i go up there and
sure enough he's there getting let in
and i'm kind of like telling the girl
like yo are you so-and-so and she's kind
of like okay everybody's kind of like
you're not supposed to be here you know
security guy's like what are you doing
up here the line's back there i'm like
yo dude i'm actually with him
you know what i mean like these people
don't know who i am and don't care and
i'm kind of like i'm just but you know
you got to hold your ground because they
you know you know just cause somebody
tell you to do something don't mean you
necessarily have to do it if you know
you got some stuff going on you know so
then i see my boy and he's like i'll be
right don't worry so then i'm like okay
then he tells the girl she's like she's
exasperated just like i got another
person i have to get in you know what i
mean uh but it was it is what it is so
then
i finally get in okay and then the guy's
like yo man you know and i'm like hey
you know it's like thanks for coming i'm
like wow this is like pretty cool he's
like well where are we going i didn't
know where the seats were okay so
man
we get down to
we get down to the uh
we get down we had to take this
escalator and then we got to like you
know we're going past all these people
you know everybody's got a mask on by
the way uh to at the start of the game
at the start of the game and going
everybody got a mask on all right but
we'll get to like what happened in the
end so then we get down and then now
we're like
we're like
in this like swanky area man
we in this like swanky
buffet is right there you know there's
so many people like that are like
opening doors for you and like would you
like some food and i was like what
and then we get out and we're like
we're like
at the end zone
we're sitting
like literally
15 feet from the end zone
and i'm like
mind blown okay
and if you're watching on if you're
listening sorry
later
you got to go to youtube if you want to
see so i have some pictures so first
that's me and the boys uh you know tommy
lee and jeremy renner right both cool
dudes so i take a picture with them you
know because i was excited about that
you know what i mean
but and then like as the game was about
to start
one of the freaking football players of
the rams because where we were sitting
all of the rams i believe all of their
family and friends were sitting above so
that's where all the rams tickets were
for the players so the players kept
coming over to be like waving at your
sister and their wife and whatever right
so this guy comes over i don't even know
who the hell this dude is number 42 he's
standing right next to me and he's like
hey man i was like what up dude
good luck today you know what i mean and
then i was like can we take a picture
and he was like you know sure he shook
my hand and i was like look at me i'm
just cheesing because i'm so
excited that it was like i was like
right there like you can see you can't
if you can see in this picture like you
know that's the end zone right there man
i mean it was it was bananas and then
like so like during the game you know i
gotta i have more pictures but i'm not
gonna show you all the pictures it's
stupid but there's like odell beckham is
like right there you know what i mean
and you know you can see some of them on
my instagram if you go to eric griffin
on my instagram but you know
so
you know we're like we're just sitting
on these dope seats and then you know
i'm meeting these people and like when
you meet like when you meet like rich
people
okay they all like
a lot most of the time they real chill
okay
like you know they chill dudes but
they're like middle-aged white guys you
know what i mean but they all like you
know this one guy was like you know he
he makes instruments and he's like like
everybody knows him he was the chillest
rich dude i've ever met okay and he's
there just you know
cool you know i mean here's another guy
that owns like 17 restaurants this other
guy this you know it was that kind of
vibe and then here's like freaking
jeremy renner you know what i mean who
i'm kind of like it's like damn you know
what i mean hi
[Laughter]
and like he was um
he was a 49ers fan okay which was great
because we were just going at it all
game so then like
he disappears for the first half because
he goes and he's in the owner's box with
the 49ers because he's a 49 he grew up
in the bay area he'd been a 49ers fan
since the 80s he told me so he's like
you know he off doing that but it's not
good seats the owner's box is like way
up they're looking at the game on tv but
i'm sure it's like swanky whatever right
so this guy he comes back at halftime
and he's been drinking you know what i
mean and he's just a fun like everybody
was just i don't drink so it is what it
is but i was eating the food food was
delicious they had this peruvian chicken
off the chain shout out to sofa and that
peruvian chicken and you know so then he
says to me he's like i just want to get
hammered and watch my 49ers win so we
just going at it man and he was just
just like i'm saying like just like it's
just weird experience to like hear
somebody so notable that you know you
see him and you know him face
recognition especially if you're a
marvel nerd and i'm just sitting here
chilling with him like i'm black widow
you know what i mean
you know what i'm saying and then like
you know he's like he's you know he's
he's tipsy
and he's like you know they're about to
kick a field goal and he's all like oh
if i have my bow and arrow right now i
would just shoot that out
that's what he said he was like i would
just take my bow and arrow and i would
just like you know like if like if he
was hot like if he was really hawkeye
you know so that's the kind of fun we
were having and it just was going back
and forth and back and forth and then
you know it was just so exciting like i
got wrapped up into it like it's not
like being at a football game it's not
it's not cool in terms of like watching
the game depending on where you are like
we didn't have the best seats in terms
of like really enjoying the gameplay and
until like it was like right there and
like cooper cup caught a touchdown
literally right in front of us and we
were just like ah
you know what i mean like he was right
there you know i care i kept wanting
like like you know like you know how the
quarterback has to overthrow because he
doesn't want to throw a interception i
we that's i wanted to catch the ball
like that's how it could have happened
you know what i mean and then
the rams entrance was right there so
they're like doing all their like
pregame hype stuff right in front of us
at the end of the game obj comes right
to where we are he didn't care about us
because like i said his family's right
there but they were right in front of us
you know so i got a good picture of that
on my instagram too and he's just right
there i mean it was just a dope
experience you know
and then the game was just fun to watch
too like the game was like it was back
and forth it was exciting but
i'm just telling you about my uh
you know about my experience and it's
just like again like tommy lee's there
and you know we're all laughing about
the game and then all their people like
you know these guys are just you know
what i mean they just like cool
chill-ass you know
successful white dudes you know
and the guy's just a fan of mine and you
know he's seen me do comedy a bunch of
times and they just like he just is
persistent and shout out to him for
being persistent because he he asked me
to go to things all the time and i'm
always just kind of like i can't go over
you know whatever it is but listen
moving forward you're gonna see me with
them all the time
but it was like really fun and if you
see me i'm just like i'm just a cheese
ball
because
you know i just really enjoy stuff like
this so like if you look at this you
know the picture again this is just my
feeling the whole time i'm just like
like i'm 11 years old just like i can't
believe you know i'm experiencing it and
i just think that's how you should live
life anyway you know no matter how
no matter how old you are or whatever
just enjoy things as they happen and i
was really enjoying
i didn't even know who that was either
by the way i see somebody in chat saying
that who's that i don't know
he's on defense probably
you know what i mean i would have liked
it it would have been great if stafford
came over to say hi to his wife but you
know what i mean
it is what it is all right now let's get
to the playoffs okay let's get to the
playoffs let's get to um
you know
oh i should put wait hold up a second
what is this add stream marker yeah let
me put that there so let's get to the
playoffs
um
man
what what a most what an exciting ass
playoff game like the playoffs all
together so
while
while i was in the parking lot of so far
dealing with that nonsense i had the
game on my thing and i'm watching the
chiefs versus bengals and the chiefs are
dominating and it looks like well this
is it chiefs are showing who their true
colors and they really gonna do their
thing and then like so as i finally get
into the stadium they're playing the
game on the big monitor and everybody's
watching too they got cause so sophie's
got these beautiful big monitors it's
really great uh everything's electronic
i mean it was it's a really fantastic
stadium so they're showing the game and
it's tied up and i'm like joe burrow is
the truth man
where is he right uh yeah there he is
right there
joe burrow truth
dude dude is good
he may not be as big as josh allen or as
fast as lamar jackson or as dynamic as
uh um what's his name um uh patrick
mahomes
but he got that thing man
joe burrow got that thing he got that it
factor he got that i'm gonna do
everything i can to win he he very much
reminds me of tom brady and we'll get to
tom brady he reminds me of a more
talented tom brady right he got that tom
brady thing with like a arm and that
physical skills that you know tom brady
didn't have when he was that age tom
brady wasn't throwing for 466 yards in
any games when he was a second year
player okay he didn't start doing that
until he got randy moss right so i'm
just saying this is like joe burrows
like for real and i would not be
surprised if they win the super bowl you
know i i just
then you're looking at you're looking at
something real special now we're looking
at like
the best crop of young quarterbacks
we've seen in 25 years
battling for supremacy in the afc like
the afc is ridiculous
what's his name uh justin herbert
uh san diego chargers beast
josh allen beast lamar jackson beast
unanimous mvp that year patrick mahomes
beast
best young quarterback
of all time under the age of 26. just
all what he's accomplished right and now
joe burrow too you adding joe burrow
that's five guys that legit have the
ability to carry their team to the super
bowl and let's not forget
uh uh what's his name the other the
aaron rodgers still in the league um you
know all these other like sort of like
aging quarterbacks who are still who
still got some um some stuff on it so
you know that was an exciting game to
watch the the the fact that like like i
saw a press conference of patrick holmes
talking about he was trying to be greedy
and he threw that interception
you know and it's like that's you know
it's like all or nothing with him and
then like
he threw that ball to tyree kill
and the guy made a great defensive play
because if you see the replay the guy's
hand was in between his hands but once
again a ball drops off of tyree kill's
hands to me that
it's happened quite a few times where
he's
he's a little dude i think is what it is
so like he just couldn't he ain't strong
enough to like out must because he ain't
like a six
four right wide receiver you know what i
mean he's this little speedster with a
lot of athletic ability but he didn't
make that he didn't make that play and
he needed them to make that play and
then the rest is history you know
and then you know once again people
thought oh it's gonna be the same thing
again with the timeout the time out
rules you know it's like you know the
defense did their job that's why the
timeout that's what not timeout overtime
i like to overtime the way it is last
night is how overtime is supposed to
work
the offensive team gets the ball
the other team makes a defensive play
giving the ball back to their team and
now they only need to kick a field goal
to win and that's what happened so
everybody bitching last week about how
the bills didn't get a chance the number
one defense couldn't stop patrick holmes
well guess what cincinnati stopped them
and they won the game that's how it's
supposed to work i don't want to hear
about overtime anymore shut up okay
so yeah it was um it was an interesting
game but i still think
uh kansas city is a dominant team they
gonna be back next year patrick holmes
is too good and i think as he gets older
he's gonna become more savvy and i think
he's gonna realize let me pick and
choose my moments to you know to do
these things that i'm doing because
ultimately they've only gotten one super
bowl out of these four afc appearances
you know what i mean it's like
you know
and then you know so and then cincinnati
is now in the thing so now let's talk
about
excuse me so sorry damn i'm still
coughing man rams and 49ers
so like i said i'm sitting here with
renner he's a freaking 49er fan
and i'm thinking
jimmy g's finally having the best game
he's had in the playoffs up to that
point he hadn't thrown a touchdown he
still by the way has more interceptions
than touchdowns in this year's playoffs
i think he got three or four
interceptions and only two touchdowns
the two touchdowns he threw in this game
but he was balling like jimmy jesus
survivor man he a winner he just don't
have the skills to do what these other
guys can do but like he was out there
doing his thing and i was like uh oh
because they were up they had to lead
and their defense let them down because
this cooper cup and obj
give it up to obj like baker mayfield
dude you're trash man like everything
that was happening in cleveland and how
they weren't using this guy that song
baker mayfield that's on the offensive
coordinator for not using this number
one dynamic talent all-time receiver obj
in the proper way like don't i don't put
it on him because now he's here with a
quarterback that knows how to get him
the ball and the dude's balling out okay
and it also helps that you know cooper
cup is like just great so they're
doubling him and i saw it on the field
from my angle of what i'm seeing i'm
like oh they're going to go to obj here
because there was just one guy on him
and you can't guard him with one guy and
he was eating them up and stafford was
getting them the ball it was like they
were methodically moving down the field
then they got into the end zone it was
just so it was just great to watch that
and then how they came back and then
their defense stepped up finally the
defense stepped up
it was such an epic battle between i
think these two teams were like
they were they were evenly matched
except for the quarterback position
and i felt for jimmy g because i feel
like jimmy g is one
throw away
he was about this far away from being a
49er great
you know that pass in the super bowl
that he missed like he makes that pass
and the trajectory of his career is
completely different same thing last
night if that
because
sam bradford not sam bradford what's his
name um
matt stafford
he threw isn't that crazy how those are
two like similar white boy names sam
bradford and matt stafford they just
it's weird anyway they he throw he
throws it he throws an interception and
the guy drops it would have ended the
game i think the 49ers would have won
and then we'd be talking different about
jimmy g but like even that pass that
jimmy g through he was trying to like
keep the play going and the guy missed
it number 17
that guy dropped the ball
and played
earlier in the game and then he missed
that catch right there but you know it's
going to go on jimmy g so
jimmy just just he don't have it man
he missing something you know what i'm
saying
he missing something that um
you know
i don't know you just just it's just
missing something you know what i mean
um
so i don't know
you know and it's too bad for him so
luck hopefully he gets uh hopefully
he'll bounce back he'll find you know
hopefully one of these other teams like
cleveland for instance i think jimmy g
would be great in cleveland i think that
he would take cleveland to the next
level you know there's a lot of places
that jimmy g can end up say aaron
rodgers doesn't come back to
green bay get jimmy g i think jimmy g
with leflore how they play
i think he would he would uh thrive in
that system so i don't know but
you know
leads me to super bowl so i'm in la i
want a california team to win because
even if the 49ers would have went to the
super bowl i would have supported the
49ers because i'm a cali boy
and um
you know i want to see i i mean the
stories are all great and that's what
that's what's great about this year's
playoffs these stories are so fantastic
so you got the you got the rookie
quarterback who tore his acl only played
like six games his rookie year he comes
back see his second season and takes his
team to a division championship
and nfc afc championship into the super
bowl and if he wins the super bowl
what a great story that is right
so that's you know so that would be an
awesome story you know and then
you got
matt stafford maligned and
and talked about you know in detroit for
12 13 years of his career he has zero
playoff games wins three playoff
appearances you know he played with a
fantastic receiver you know he's just
heralded as being like a fan like a you
know he's got an mvp arm
really talented but he was in detroit
he had this up and down season
you know he had this up and down season
where it was like you know
he threw all these pick sixes and people
were still getting on like can he do it
can he be better than jared goff can he
get them to the super bowl can they win
can he get him over the hump that was
the expectations so all his story and
then for him to like come and play the
way he's playing and lead his team be
tom brady you know what i mean beat the
49ers who
this team hasn't beat in six this is
their first win in six games so in seven
games they they're they're one and six
versus the 49ers to get past that now
get to the super bowl and win it that
would be a great story too so but if i
have to pick i'm going with the rams
i think the rams are gonna win the game
and i think it's probably gonna be a
shootout
i think they i think rams have potential
to blow them out because the rams
offensive line is way better i'm sorry
defensive line is way better than
cincinnati's o-line that o-line is like
nine sacks in that first game against
tennessee even though they still won i
don't know i think aaron donald and
boyd's are gonna uh put to put to put to
put the whoop on that offensive line but
i would not hold it past uh you know joe
joey b or blue eyed joe over here to get
it done you know what i mean i wouldn't
be surprised if he gets it done
and then uh yeah shout out to jimmy
knives in the chat right now jimmy i
don't know where you've been but it's
good good to have you back
and as i said earlier guys if you want
to be a youtube member you're going to
get the you know though all my special
patreon only youtube videos will also be
available to youtube members
and you know patreon there's gonna be
more patreon content coming your way and
also check out eric griffin gaming you
know don't check that out too so
all right all right let's get to now um
the big announcement in the nfl
is that good old tom brady good old tom
brady is finally
retiring
and i just wanted to give uh some praise
and shout outs to good old tom brady
for uh you know all that he's done
for the nfl
um i'm not a huge i wasn't really a
patriots fan and i wasn't a tom brady
fan you know he just like i just i
always felt like he was just like just
there
you know with them and i didn't realize
how great his contribution is more than
talent
that he did for his team i'd still think
that it's a beast that bill belichick
bill belichick created and i think that
marriage that they formed that
relationship that they formed
created
the monster that they both became you
know
and tom brady took that to tampa bay and
then showed them how to win you know
what i mean but he learned that from
belichick
but tom brady got his own thing you know
what i mean that guy's a winner you know
that guy's a winner and it's like you
look at someone
like let's say you look at lebron james
who is like six seven two percent body
fat a freaking nature and you look at
him and when he doesn't achieve
we say you're not living up to your
potential because of how great you we
think you should be because of your
physical ability but think about it the
guy's been to 10 championships he's won
four
or five however many lebron james has
won you know he it's like that's still a
great career but because of his physical
attributes we look at him and go you
didn't do enough
bananas
but cut to tom brady we look at him
and then we praise the person that is
overachieved because we don't think that
his skill level was good should be doing
what he did but that just shows you how
great his other attributes are and he's
still also really fantastic quarterback
don't get me wrong the dude's accurate
great on third down
fantastic game manager fantastic leader
and all that stuff is like he just you
know he's not fast you know he doesn't
necessarily have the biggest arm you
know what i mean he's not like some of
these other guys and like and if you
look at their early championships in new
england the defense was spectacular like
the defense like he even when he won in
tampa bay last year to tampa bay look at
his numbers in the playoffs not very
good he had a three interception game in
the playoffs that defense was just
spectacular right so he's always been
that guy he's always a guy you can kind
of go and you can poke at but when you
when it's all said and done seven super
bowls man the guy is a winner he's
winning on the field he's winning off
the field with his businesses with his
like personality like like you cannot
not like tom brady like what i realized
is i just didn't like the patriots i
didn't like boston
but tom brady is just a likable fun
dude who like when he started doing the
commercials and stuff we were like oh
man this dude's cool and now he's gonna
like go off into the sunset you know
with his tb-12 with his production
company
i would not be surprised if we see him
and you know in ownership or something
or maybe he wants to be on tv i would
love to hear his perspective like you
know who knows man but kudos to you so i
just want to give a shout out thanks to
tom brady for you know 22 years
of like making me hate him you know
because he's beating my teams and
winning and stuff like that you know
only one time i i uh like as many times
as i go to vegas for the super bowl a
lot
for like years i would go to vegas and i
love betting on the game and all those
little like prop bets but anytime i
would always bet against the patriots so
i've lost only one time
only one time i bet for the patriots it
was when they played seattle
and then they won at the last second and
i was like oh my god i can't believe
this so
you know what i mean it's just it's it's
uh kudos to tom brady for you know just
22 years
uh fantastic uh football so as i'm
looking at the chat right now i see some
things in here
uh somebody asked a question is stafford
better than goff uh yeah i'd take
stafford over goff
yeah for sure uh you know and it's in
it's because right now they've done the
exact same thing
you know they got their team to the
super bowl and i would take stafford you
know
i think most people would but uh they
have a chance to win it which is what
you know they felt like they couldn't do
i mean look at detroit man detroit was
terrible this year they won two games
you know what i mean two games so
regardless of whatever's going on over
there you think come on you what are you
worth i mean i think a great quarterback
is worth you know six
five six seven games of just like great
quarterback play to get your team over
the hump even if it's bad
russell wilson does that every single
year i mean russell wilson hasn't won
the super bowl and his teams just are up
and down but he himself is good for six
to seven games of how his game play
jared goff don't got that he don't got
that
all right
um but anyways
um
that's that guys all right so that's uh
my football
that's the football part of the show
uh and then once again kudos to tom
brady all right i do i i have been
talking about this show on my patreon
only but i'm gonna get get caught up
right now with you guys and i'm gonna
talk about this right now so this is the
entertainment portion of riverwood
griffin let's get to the entertainment
stuff boba fett
i talk about episode four already i've
talked about it already boring as hell
but while i was doing that
live patreon podcast my chat was all
like yo dude episode five is great you
gotta watch episode five so i was super
excited i was like episode five is
better okay good
because that usually happens you know
things get better as the season goes so
i was like all right let me check this
out so then i uh went and watched
episode 5
and i was like oh
this is what you know how you make boba
fett better
you do an episode of mandalorian
that's what they did they did an episode
of mandalorian
in boba fett
that was episode five it was a it was
episode 11 of mandalorian
but i'ma tell you what messed me up now
and all the people in chat that were
sending me messages and comments
trying to explain to me the timeline
you're all wrong
when is this
like
when is this
happening
because
i don't know what's going on so they
showing the let's just go through it
right now
and you can explain it to me in the
comments okay
they showing you the timeline of
return of the jedi
that
this is boba fett in the sarlacc pit
okay where he's being digested by this
monster
they showing a flashback that boba fett
has
awakened
he grabs the stormtrooper's air to
breathe and he busts his way out of
the sarlacc pit and now he's laying in
the desert where the jawas come and
steal all his [ __ ]
then he is picked up by the sand people
and taken to their village
when was this
you hear what i'm saying
when was this
how long then was he one in this like
was he in the sarlacc pit for
20 years
and
how long was this how long was he with
the desert people was he with them for
10 years 20 years like how long was this
timeline
and the reason why i say this is this
when was the mandalorian like when was
the mandalorian timeline
uh compared to star wars return of the
jedi empire strikes back and all those
other movies when was the timeline
for the mandalorian because mandalorian
and boba fett are happening at the same
time
so when i saw mando in this i was like
what how this is after mandalorian
because he had the spear
this is and he's already given up uh
the boogie woogie or whatever the little
baby yoda whatever his name is juba
booby or whatever i don't know the name
whatever you guys can tell me anything
so
when was this you see what i'm saying
so now
um
uh you know mando did all his stuff and
now he's about to link up with boba fett
so when is this timeline so somebody
said here that it's like five years
after return of the jedi
i mean okay
i can rock with that so he was in the
pit for however how long he worked his
way out and then he was at that camp for
like five years but i could see him
being at the camp for longer than five
years you know what i mean maybe that's
what it is but i didn't realize that
demando timeline though see this is what
we have to say the mandalorian timeline
is soon after return of the jedi that
that's what that would mean
right
uh gorgu or gor whatever
whatever is it gorgu is that his name
gorgu so so that's what i want to figure
out so i need somebody in the chat so
when you chat not the chat but on the
comments now explain to me the timeline
start with return of the jedi
start with return of the jedi
it's ended the empire has been
destroyed
now
this is
you know boba fett comes out so
mandalorian and whatever happened what
was happening with boba fett happened in
that five year let's say he's at the the
thing for five years that's when at the
same time all that stuff would man the
mandalorian was happening at the same
time too in the last like year four or
five of
boba fett being with the desert people
that's when that was happening so now
mandalorians gonna work with boba fett
it's messing the timeline up for me and
i don't know what's going on
but i will say this mandalorian is a ten
times better show than boba fett
and so and and
and the storytelling is better the
directing is better
the performances are better
the you know and so they're going to
combine them i'm cool with this now
because it's going to make boba fett
better because up to this point right
now boba fett not good
okay not it's not bad it just was
underwhelming it was kind of blah
you know and so again they spiced it up
with this great mandalorian episode of
boba fett so now let's see if like i
think they're gonna do 10 episodes or is
it 13 i'm not sure how many episodes
they're gonna do
so
they do like if that's episode five and
if they do just eight three more oh
that'll be disappointing um
that's gonna be pretty good to see how
mando and boba fett interact with each
other but you know my you know and again
so i will be talking more about boba
fett when i watch this week's episode
but that'll be on my patreon only
um
and
youtube member only videos so check that
out
and thanks for being here
okay
um now the next uh in the last show
that i want to talk about is this and
i'm not going to talk about the whole
show just going to give you a little
a little little heads up because i've
been i started watching it and i'm only
on like two or three episodes in but
it's called archive 81.
anybody else in chat watching archive 81
oh it looks like my chat is a little
behind
but that's okay
um yeah archive 81 um
yeah it's uh
an archivist
an archivist to hire to restore a
collection of tapes
finds himself
recon what is it what is that word
oh reconstructing the work of a
filmmaker and her investigation into a
dangerous
cult
so
yeah you know it stars this guy oh i'm
not going to be able to get his name
right manandu
man
man ma moundu something or other
shout out to you bro i'm so sorry i
didn't get your name right um
yeah it's um anyways
archive 81
i'm enjoying it okay so like the show
opens up this guy actually you know he
gets videotapes and old tapes and he he
restores them okay
and
you know then it's like so what it is is
like
he's this is how this is the little
filmmaking tool they're using
he's watching the restored videotapes
okay of this girl
who vanished or whatever is going on
with her
and
then the the the show kind of like
melds into showing that girl's story at
the same time
so you get in like a perspective of okay
the guy's watching this and we're also
learning things
because they kind of you know the world
opens up and it's like we're inside the
tape
it's a good show
you know it's but it's like spooky
and
i don't know
if there's a
supernatural element to the show yet
because when that happens
that's always
like funky to me
like because like because like i need to
know
it's kind of like i remember this is
dumb but i remember watching uh dream
girls the movie jamie foxx beyonce
now i know dream girls is a musical
right
but that
but the movie was on was going on for
like
almost 20 minutes
and then people started singing and
dancing in the streets and i was like
oh wait a minute is this a musical like
i know it was a musical but i didn't
realize the movie was also a musical
that people just gonna be singing for no
reason right so that messed me up you
know like i wish i would have known that
and that's just me being stupid but i
wish i would have known that but because
i didn't know that it messed me up and i
didn't enjoy the movie
that's how i feel about
this
show
like
remember to show lost
you know they're on this island whatever
i was on board with lost
for however many seasons
until that black smoke monster came then
i was out because i was like oh this
can't really happen
because up to that point the way they've
been doing it
you you think oh this could actually
happen in real life you said you could
easily suspend your disbelief but when
you add the supernatural fact
supernatural stuff with no explanation
now you're going oh this is witchcraft
or this is like you know
otherworldly stuff that like i wasn't on
board with that yet now if you start off
with that you know if you open up with
this is going to be ghosts and goblins
and dragons and all that kind of stuff
then i'm on board because my brain has
clicked in and now i'm looking for that
when they did that and lost i was out
cause now
all my feelings and
things i was all my my my theories about
the show everything i thought that was
happening
it flew out the door because now magic
can happen
i don't know what's going on with this
show yet
i don't know if this is like aliens i
don't know if this is demonic i haven't
watched it all so maybe you've already
watched it all so you already know so
don't spoil it for me so i you know look
at me telling you don't spoil it for me
when i spoil [ __ ] for you all the time
but you get what i'm saying like i don't
know if
this cult is like it's gonna be some
devil stuff is this gonna be like the
omen or if this is gonna be like this is
just you know stuff that can happen by
you know rich cult people doing rich
cult people stuff so i don't know so
it's a little exciting just trying to
wait and see how they're going to reveal
it you know because because then like
okay this is what this is another thing
they do in the show weird stuff's
happening and then like you go uh oh
this is magic but then he wakes up from
a dream then you're like ooh
he was just dreaming that but at the
same time you're like was he dreaming
or did that happen and he just ended up
in bed you know what i mean so
i'm enjoying seeing the process
uh of the thing but it's a lot i i i
recommend watching it if you don't got
another show to watch
it's super artsy fartsy too it's artsy
fartsy
you know like they're making like
choices and i like that like i like
seeing how filmmakers or or you know uh
show creators show running the director
and the cinematographer like this is
what they're deciding to do with this
material and how they're presenting it i
do like how they're presented it i think
the star of the show is doing a great
job
um
you know what i mean let's let wait let
me let me get let me let's let me put
him on the screen so we get him right
um
this uh african dude i think he's like
he must be from africa because his name
look look at me i don't even know what
am i saying but i feel like matt why do
you say his name
modu i feel like mamodu is african so i
think i i think it's fair to say this
dude from africa
right but he's doing a great job you
know
he got just enough fear and like
um
um curiosity his character that you're
just kind of like ooh i wonder what's
gonna happen next so
kudos to him
kudos to uh
uh the show archive 81
so i do
recommend that you uh watch it and tell
me what you think
you know what i mean
tell me what you think so
you know
um as i said
uh we're getting a new we're getting a
new couch
and when i get the new couch
i might go live from the couch one day
i think that'll be kind of cool just be
downstairs doing the episode live
rachel hasn't been on i got to get
rachel on she hasn't been on in a while
so uh we'll check that out and uh again
i can't stress to you enough how
appreciative i am of you guys
fans um you know like subscribe share
all that stuff comment troll all of that
uh check me out on you know all the
other podcasts i do
but uh you know it's uh and then i also
twitch live you know i'm gonna be
twitching after this episode so if you
want to check me out go to eric griffin
cayman which i would love to follow
so check me out there
but you know it's uh it's pretty
it's pretty great you know uh the fans
have been pretty good uh you guys are
great and please like like i say if you
want more content from me i am now
officially doing a lot of not a lot but
i'm doing more content from my patreon
channel and that's patreon.com eric
griffin and if you want to be even if
you want to be a youtube member here i'm
putting that content there too just for
you guys
uh you know then after like after i
think after like two or three weeks i
might just make it live for everybody
but you know you get or that that early
access to that by being a patreon member
um so thank you for that for the people
that have and thank you for all the the
youtube members you guys i appreciate
you guys too that's that's pretty cool
and so like i say uh i want my
i want the rams to win uh but i would
not be surprised if since he wins and
you know let's
you know
to recap that so that that's gonna be i
think that's gonna be a really super
exciting super bowl and i hope it really
is because that would be like just a
just a cherry on top of like what a what
a like just a fantastic season of
football that we've experienced you know
what i mean
[Music]
but we did it again
riffing with griffin
tell your friends y'all
um and also for my patreon people if
anybody's watching i'm gonna start
giving those patreon shout outs
and you guys like if you have questions
then get into the comments man i i will
start you know
every now and then get in there and read
in comments
next week i have a guest i've already
taped the episode
um the
rapper and political activist anomaly
from instagram he's actually really cool
dude so we have a really great in-depth
conversation so look out for that
episode next week
and again i will have a bonus episode of
roofing with griffin for patreon and
that's gonna come out probably on
wednesday i'm gonna do that so look out
for that and i just wanna thank you once
again for being here and i will see you
on twitch
make sure you come check me out twitch
eric griffin gaming
and thanks for being here y'all
[Music]
very groovy
[Music]